[Music]
one of the most common misconceptions
about medieval combat is that armor
could be easily pierced you can see
Knights in full plate armor in chainmail
being stepped to that or cut in half all
the time and it's nonsense
[Music]
today we will demonstrate how it
actually works in a real world and in
the game as well we have a lot of
weapons professionals and also dangerous
enemies that you're going to cut in half
and eat afterwards every weapon is good
against different types of armor and
Kingdom Come it's reflected in three
different types of stats we have blunt
slash and step damage for every piece of
armor and weapon
[Music]
using salt against an opponent without
an armor wielding an axe is a advantage
in speed and distance but using the same
sword is pretty useless against full
plate armor
don't get me wrong so it is a very
deadly weapon this is very sharp 14th
century sword and just look how easily
it slices to this peak which is very
similar to human body
so you can see that one blow is enough
for game over without proper protection
so now let's see how the sword deals
with plate armor
so you can see that the combatant would
be safe from bleeding and cuts it which
stood pretty heavy blows even the chain
mail and this is not very expensive one
withstood stabbing and slashing here the
source penetrated the gambeson easily as
you can see but it it's not failure of
the chainmail so you can fight with the
sword against Armour and there are
special technique that can be used and
we have them in the game as well but
there is a better equipment for the
fight with armored Knight like this
hammer
[Music]
so surprisingly the armour which stood a
lot what's most surprising is that the
sword is almost intact there is a
slightly damaged tip and there is one
little dent here but even those massive
blows to the armor didn't make a scratch
on the blade which is very surprising
you could saw that the polearm
penetrated the chainmail quite easily so
you'll be pretty screwed with just a
chain mail and gambeson against this
huge pull arm so now let's take this
down and see how the figure in ended up
these holes are from the pole arm but
the chest is intact even the warhammer
didn't do any damage here we can see the
stabbing of the sword so it would be
probably people but you can see that the
armor is pretty damn powerful and full
plate armor makes you a medieval tank
basically
[Music]
the weapons we use during our little
experiment are of course new but this is
very nice an extremely expensive
collection of via coupe of 14 and 15
century weapons found in Bohemia so
these are really actual archaeological
findings for example this is 14th
century bastard sword with golden in way
it's not the heaviest heavier than 100
sword we used but this is really I never
saw original sword lot of other weapons
the sword that he used is produced by
the same smithy in ARMA Epona as the
sword that we are going to send to our
backers so you will get the same quality
as this one yeah it's a lot of
interesting stuff this is for example
mystery core that is used when the
knight is down you can like step him in
unprotected parts that's why it's called
mr. Kord couple axis Keys quest item a
lot of arrow and bolt crossbow bolt so
this is really awesome
so as you can see it's very different
than what many people think and it works
exactly the same way in our game we have
three types of damage for layers of
armor and more than 30 damage zones on
every character in the game so it really
matters where how and by what you hit
your enemy every weapon is actually
phreatic numbers how good it is in
stabbing how good it is in slashing and
how strong the weapon is when you make a
bond strike every weapon also has a
different weight which defines how fast
is going to be and how much stamina you
will need to use it each weapon and
armor also different quality a step that
defines how easily it's going to get
damaged death creates a lot of
complexity and space for different
fighting styles
you
[Music]
if you want to see more about this you
can watch our previous armor an RPG
video